- Donc, ici, c'est notre chambre
froid où on entrepose
les arbres.- Des pommiers, des ,
des pruniers, des chênes, des
noyers: i y a ici des milliers
d'arbres qui iront bientôt
s'enracirs. Dans cette
pépinière de Chaudière-
Appalaches, les ventes ont
grimpé de 40 % l'an dernier et
on s'attend à une autre hausse
d'au moins 20 % cette année.
NICOLAS AUGER, copropriétaire,
Pépinière Ancestrale
- C'est la folie, on se le
cachera pas. Depuis la pandémie,
il y a eu augmentation à chaque
année.- Pour répondre à la dema,
on a doublé la superficie
des serres.
- Mais dès l'automne dernier,
la grande majorité de la
production était déjà réservée
en vue du printemps.
- Dépêchez-vous si vous voulez
en avoir, il en reste encore un
petit peu, mais l'inventaire
diminue. C'est vraiment
onnant àonnant àonnant àonnant e
les gens réservent.
MARIANNE BARIL, copropriétaire,
Pépinière Ancestrale
- Cette année, dès le mois de
décembre-janvier, il y avait
beaucoup de ruptures de stocks.
Ça fait que, oui, il y a encore
un peu de choix, mais il faut
être vipiton en
ce moment!
- C'est surtout les arbres
fruitiers qui ont la cote.
La récolte est en quelque sorte
une récompense, une activité
familiale qu'on peut faire dans
sa propre cour.
- La pandémie, je pense qu'elle
a eu une vraiment vraiment vrait
significative sur l'intérêt des
gens pour l'horticulture,
le retour à la terre.
- Même si la neige n'a pas
encore complètement fondu,
certains se précipitent déjà
pour acheter leurs semences.
- Cinq graines... il n'y en
a pas beaucoup mai
ça te fait cinq plants.
- Cette cliente ne veut pas
répéter l'expérience de l'an
dernier.
- Je me suis fait prendre, il y
en avait un peu moins de
semences, tout ça. Donc je
voulais être sûre d'avoir ce que
je voulais (rires). Du basilic,
des carottes, concombres, en fin
de semaine, on part les piments.
e jardinage,
on se prépare pour le coup
d'envoi on.
D'ici la mi-avril, cette serre
sera remplie d'arbres,
de plantes, de fleurs et
de clients.
STEVE LUNEAU, copropriétaire,
Les Serres Lambert
- Si on recule par rapport à il
y a deux ans, c'est vraiment
impres
viennent tous en même temps.
- Le nombre de clients a bondi
de 20 % depuis le début de
la pandémie. Et certains ont
déjà passé leur commande.
- On a beaucoup, beaucoup de
végétaux qui sont réservés,
des gens qui ont peur de pas en
avoir ou qui ont peur qu'on en
manque, qui réservent tout de
ui sont mui sont mui sont mui sà
payer tout de suite pour les
avoir pour quand ils vont être
prêts mettons au moins de juin,
juillet, août.
générale adjointe, Québec Vert
- Les fleurs annuelles, les
plants de légumes, c'est produit
100% au Québec ça.n'yn'yn'yn'yny
a pas de problèmes pour que nos
producteurs répondent à la
demande cette année, même chose
pour les vivaces.
- Après deux ans de pandémie,lee
la province se sont adaptés.
On promet qu'il n'y aura pas
de pénurie.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Vic